hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
remember in 1994 when Stargate came out
for those who don't the build-up was
incredible
all they showed was this magical gate
that could teleport people to somewhere
else where did they go what do they find
when they got there you had to go see
the movie to find out wow I wonder what
it could be this is going to keep me
awake all night I'm gonna see the movie
right now just to find out
holy crap was that stupid so what aliens
invented the pyramids are you nuts yeah
all those Egyptian morons with a
brilliant groundbreaking designs they're
nothing to do with it it was just a
Lian's and the ruler of the known
universe is that chick with the dead
from The Crying Game
boom the last time ever watch a movie by
Dean Junkers again say you remember in
1996 when Independence Day came out it
was done by the same idiots who did
Starkie but look all it showed in the
advertising was the White House giving
blood that's it nothing else whoa how
the hell does that happen this movie
must be good I mean sure they messed up
with Starkey but maybe this will be a
good one
besides I just gotta know how the White
House blows up I'm gonna go check it out
right now
sad back thanks mommies even worse than
the last one so what the President of
the United States gets in a jet to fight
off aliens are you high yeah that's it
I'm done
I am never watching another movie by
these morons ever again ever
no no not interested No
god damn it cars my hunger for what
destruction
alright so even though the filmmakers
made two horrible movies before Godzilla
hooked us all in with its clever
advertising how because they never show
the monster you had to see the movie in
order to see the monster so advertisers
thought up a brilliant strategy of
describing the monster for us like
vehicles that said his foot is as long
as this bus or billboards and said his
head is as big as this sign it was
downright genius alright guys so you
suckered us in yet again please please
can you try and give us a good movie
this time I mean it's Godzilla it can't
be that difficult to make something
that's just so on entertaining oh you
shut up guys you did it
you actually did it you made Godzilla
even less credible than it already was
somebody get these douchebags an award
for sucking ah so if I had to sit
through this pile of Dino droppings that
figure you ought to share the pain with
me the film starts out with oddly enough
a monster attacking the Japanese haven't
seen that before
what's your commbuys money what's the
matter
after that scene we get our next
horrible disaster Matthew Broderick he
plays our main character called Nick Oh
Tatopoulos it's Tatopoulos
whatever he plays as a nerdy white guy
who wastes classes and is socially weird
hey that sounds like the nerdy white guy
who wears glasses and socially awkward
from stargate or the nerdy white guy who
wears glasses as socially awkward from
Independence Day but don't you worry
this character is far far different he
is much more annoying than any of those
other guys so the job of mr. metropolis
citta polis whatever is to study
earthworms and how they grow over a
certain period of time this leads to in
getting the clever nickname of the worm
guy Matthew Broderick plays a wormy
person finally some ideal casting so the
military comes to taken to a piece of
land in Panama where they want him to
analyze something a little bigger than
an earthworm here's your sample studying
what sample you're standing in it
they want to analyze the footprint of a
giant chicken the killer poultry is not
on his list of study specimens good old
testosterone
siddhappa less whatever agrees to study
whatever made that hole in the ground
meanwhile in Tahiti the French guy from
the professional interviews one of the
survivors of the monstrous shipwreck
whoa a lighter
I see giant radioactive lizards the size
of the kingdom but a lighter that gets
my attention
did you see old man okay apparently fire
translates English into Japanese but I
digress did you see old man
Leticia her judo judo
this seems threatening at first but take
a look at what Godzilla actually
translates out to Latricia could you top
next we cut to New York City where a
woman named Audrey wants to try and get
a reporting job from an anchor she's
working for a played by Harry Shearer
it's gonna consider Lee for the city
safe why don't we talk about it over
dinner tonight
your place mr. Kamin you're married yes
and you're very beautiful have I ever
told you that before Wow subtle do you
think he tries that on every woman he
meets hi I'm Charles my hobbies are
marriage cheating and having sexual
intercourse with you you want to have
dinner and then we cut to another
location in Jamaica Jesus how many
locations are there it's like they're
kicked out every country that they try
to film it where it turns out that
Bowser is still on the loose as it turns
out he attacked yet another ship and
much like this movie it was dragged
under so what could this giant
perversion of nature possibly be this
animal is much too big to be some kind
of lost dinosaur a hybrid caused by the
fallout on these islands uh-huh like
your earthworms
yes I believe that this is a mutated
aberration just like my career I'm
acting next we cut to Audrey's friends
played by a very annoying vicki lewis
and even more annoying hank azaria
telling you he is dark he's a douchebag
gutter slime dog crap puked chuckles hey
I'm eating you'll see I'm eating come on
I'm trying to be all ooh you're cute but
Bing boom BAM Jetson stuff she's
suddenly distracted when she sees mr.
tap-dance Alice citta police whatever on
the TV screen
while that's going on we see the mayor
of New York and is it appeasing the city
tell me of these two look familiar at
all
oh they're spoofing Siskel and Ebert I
see
apparently mayor Ebert is an anger
obsessed screamer who spends most of his
time eating candy while his a gene is a
slimy little yes-man who blindly agrees
with everything he says take-back Siskel
and Ebert how dare you have an opinion
but I don't get it why are they making
fun of these two in the first place
they're like America's most loved
critics oh maybe it's because they never
gave thumbs up to any of your movies
well maybe if you got your thumbs out of
your asses and start producing good
films we'd agree with you but dude they
don't even take advantage of this even
Gene Siskel the critic they were
satirizing asked the question if you're
going to go to the trouble of putting us
in a monster movie why don't you at
least take advantage of having the
monster either eat or squash us that's a
good point here's your shot to really
get back in these critics who hated all
your films in a monster movie no less
and you don't even have the monster kill
them or rip them to shreds that's really
bad when you're getting criticized by
the critic you're criticizing because
you didn't criticize them enough try
saying that three times fast but the
director is not the only one preying on
the innocent
Godzilla finally arrives showing his
face in New York you're running a
prehistoric muck hook ow
its Cloverfield that's eight years early
so he Rob's and stomps and even goes
pants a news station where voice actors
Nancy Cartwright seasoned walk by I
think your story just walked by the
window okay wait a minute Nancy
Cartwright Harry Shearer Hank Azaria is
this just a Simpsons be Union what's
nice the cast of scooby-doo is gonna
show him flying sawing Scoob look out
and Scott
holy shit
like you said it Scoob so he roars and
screams and tears I'm good chunks of the
city and then out of nowhere he suddenly
disappears after its initial attack Tia
disappeared he suddenly disappears
hottie lose track of a 20-story high
dinosaur it's perfect
an island water on all sides of like no
other island in the world this is a
place where he can easily hide a city of
eight million people is a good place to
hide this isn't like the Bourne Identity
where he can just blend into his
surroundings my guess is that giant
prehistoric lizard is probably going to
stand out so they look over the damage
that the amazing disappearing Godzilla
left behind in what city officials are
describing as the worst act of
destruction since the World Trade Center
bombing uh yeah the World Trade Center
bombing I'm sure that's the only huge
disaster that New York will ever know
all right I'm bailing out on this one
you seen that Godzilla has left a long
line of destruction he even came to his
way through the MetLife building haha
that's funny
but wait really look at this how is it
possible that that thing is still
standing new architecture isn't just one
of those big paper things that you
ripped through at the beginning of a
football game it's a little more
complicated than that so while the city
is being evacuated our heroes trying to
think of a way to lure the monster out
so they can get a good shot they then
come up with a brilliant idea fish of
course giant piles of fish because as we
all know lizards do not eat fish they
eat bugs
what are you crazy give me better I'm
putting a giant ant farm in the middle
of the city you retards so our brilliant
and obviously unlisted prone hero looks
over this amazing site
that's a lot of fish what that's a lot
of fish that's a lot of fish that's I
don't get it that's a lot of fish the
soul I mean is that meant to be funny
I'd love to pause at the end for the
audience to laugh I mean but what's the
joke I could have just easily said
that's a hat that's a wall that's a lot
of fish I mean how is that funny
you could have said a lot of things
they're like I got a fishy feeling about
this or it's like shooting fish in a
barrel out here it wouldn't have been
funny but at least I would have been
actual jokes that's a lot of fish you
can spend years trying to figure out why
the hell that's supposed to be funny and
not get anywhere that's a lot of fish
look you could literally just put in
gibberish and that at least would have
been a little bit funnier he looks over
this amazing site turns to the other guy
and says poppity pop pop pop and that
actually will have gotten a little bit
of the laughs just nonsense off the top
of my head is funnier than these guys
trying to willingly produce written
humor thank so after mr. tim monopolist
citt police whatever makes his
brilliant remark guess who comes to
dinner
wow I guess Bugs Bunny is lost again I
knew I should've taken it lifts going up
Albuquerque no it's the poorly
computer-generated Godzilla and all his
unconvincing pixelization did you get my
good side
we say he eats broderick no not today
apparently someone also forgot to tell
Godzilla that lizards don't eat fish
because he takes the bait literally hook
line and sinker
but the military attack which means of
course more stomping and running around
the city killing jobs do our country
proud
hello to the UM I was so pitifully
embarrassed look he's even breathing
fire just like a real lizard would do
look at the scene it's practically
ripping off every single flying scene
ever done in motion picture history echo
for our use the palm scoop locked on
zerkin at 1 million at 7 in his
situation reports phones and abilities
around him the heat seekers can lock
their on target in the
but it turns out the military really
sucks at their job because they actually
turned out to destroy more of a city
than the monster does seriously I don't
get how they can't shoot this thing I
mean see really that hard to miss
especially love this scene where the
monster actually manages to fake them
out
dude this is a game of tag just use any
of your basic five senses to find him
after he starts dry humping a building
Godzilla manages to I'm not kidding
disappear again what is wrong with these
idiots are they just looking at their
shoelaces when he's around at me white
hop we did nothing it them oh that's not
true we fed him Oh several good soldiers
just lost their lives dick so after that
we see Audrey as she comes across mr.
tacker Dovan hump a shire rikki-tikki
hamster master Polly wolly wanna bing
bang ji supercalifragilistic knick-knack
paddywhack give the dog a banana fanna
for fresca hickory dickory hockety
pockety wacky wacky Angelina Francesca
the third citta polis whatever as they
decide to catch up on old times you're
still mad at me well give up without a
phone call letter nothing all this time
yeah yeah I guess I am still a little
mad
that was eight years ago some people
change
most people don't um I'm sorry but uh
you are aware that there was just a
giant really liked a monster Romans of
the city right eight years is a long
time can I make a cup of tea
sure that'd be nice by the way did you
see all that fish there was a lot of it
she stares over as apparently her
ex-boyfriend keeps a lot of pictures of
her lying around most women would find
this creepy but the scripts out of touch
reality suggests that she finds it
charming so charming that she steals a
videotape of top-secret information from
him so she can post it all over the news
wow what a war meanwhile as helicopters
continue to search for plot brother it
comes across a stunning realization
Godzilla is pregnant how can that be
males can't wait eggs not if he
reproduces asexually Wow how
dramatically convenient the blood that I
collected revealed that the creature is
either about to lay eggs or already has
gentlemen we could have sequels horrible
horrible sequels these eggs are gonna
hatch very quickly how could you
possibly know that the fish the fish
that we found on the subway he's not
collecting all this food just for
himself and I don't think I need to
remind you gentlemen that that was in
fact a lot of fish but the army doesn't
listen to Broderick please as they
discovered that he accidentally leaked
information to the news and his booted
off the assignment aw Jay tries to
apologize for being a bitch was a
terrible thing to do I never should have
done that good luck with your new career
really think you have what it takes I
thought we had something I thought we
had fish but Jean Arado pops up as it
turns out that he's part of a secret
French organization as they set out to
stop Godzilla because they care about
the Americans can you believe us to
expect such a thing I mean not the
driveway - I've been lizard the French
trying to help Americans Oh Nicholas
because the fish plant works so well the
first time the military plans to do it
again only this time they learn the
monster out into Central Park because as
we all know no one can survive Central
Park in the middle of night Godzilla
comes out for the eleventh rainy day in
a row and again falls for the bait all
right
I'm just going for the fish we cool we
cool
oh you can't tease with some more
explosions and obnoxious kabooms
Godzilla runs to the city yet again I'm
starting to think you don't like me very
much
oh good he jumped into the Hudson River
he'll be dead in a matter of seconds but
the Green October is standing by his
afters rapscallion back to Kingdom Come
directed I just wanted to be on Broadway
you think that'd be the end but nope
our heroes drives into the demolished
subway to find the nest of eggs that
Broderick was talking about but wait how
are the friend you gotta pass by as
Americans who you boys win uh
we're with the three-two sir I didn't
ask you soldier you got a problem
talking why no sir I'm fine all right
keep it moving I'll thank you very much
Elvis Presley movies what's the king
yeah could be worse
he kept honest Jerry Lewis impression I
just wanted to write on the Underground
choo-choo with the wheels in this box
and the lady
so they come across a destroyed Madison
Square Garden where they make their
discovery quiet I think I hear fish
faster than you can say green eggs and
ham
our heroes come across the nest of
Cadbury eggs from hell but the eggs
start to hatch and rather than just
shoot the damn things the fronts do what
they're best known for give up and scram
and this is the part of the movie I like
to call guess what part of Jurassic Park
they're stealing from
it seems that behind every door that
seems to be a blockade of Monsters
Broderick should know he checks all of
them once again the mystical gumballs of
Doom's seemed to get the monsters to
slip as they get out of the building
just before the military blows it to
smithereens so this should be the end of
them we'll be right
no because Godzilla actually resurrects
himself back to life he is the son of
gods along so this leads to yet another
chase scene where our heroes race across
the city in a taxi turn the meter off
turn the meter off you know they help
with this thing just a few too many
times you breathe fire at them they just
turn around
he corners them in a tunnel they just
turn on their headlights they get
trapped inside his mouth hey go to
corner I know this is probably a bad
time to mention this but do you guys
remember all that fish wasn't that
something
so he gets tangled up in the Brooklyn
Bridge as the military throw everything
they got direct hit but the target is
still moving sir well circle around and
fire again just blow shit up it's all we
know how to do
geesh what the hell else can they throw
in a damn thing
use the anvil lose the ocean liner
that's it bring it nothing boys after
the creature finally goes down we get
that lame scene where I guess you're
supposed to actually feel sorry for it
I've had more emotions for my toilet
brush what have we become because we'll
never find out all right
so hot we into titties get together
genius Ebert of vulgar thumbs down and
even our French friend manages to say oh
why thank you for your help my friend
maybe one day I too can be fascinated by
fish and they all live happily ever
after
oh do they
in my world this movie ISM why because
this movie bumped big-time finally
bringing down that rain of
special-effects disaster movies that
were in and of themselves disaster
movies true this in director trying to
lure us back with shitty movies like The
Day After Tomorrow and 10000 BC but
audiences are finally learning their
lesson about avoiding this groups crap
and if by chance you think that their
latest disaster movie 2012 might finally
be that one good disaster film you think
they might make just remember oh god I
love that cartoon I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you know hat
that's a lot of fish